Because I grew up sick I spent most of
my time at home often in bed.
Sci-fi and fantasy and fiction it just became like, my own little escape world.
Having cystic fibrosis can be a bit of a
lonely experience. It's really hard to
connect with people in person. CF has
definitely like a younger life
expectancy. I've had friends who have
passed away at 21, at 19. It's given me a
lot of drive to move forward and see my
life as something that's precious and  meaningful.
I decided that if I was going to
do anything I wanted to go to school.
I was like well if I'm gonna die young and
if I'm gonna go to university before I
die I'm going to go to like the best
school. I worked really hard for it and
then I did it. I really feel passionate
about using what I've learned here at
Harvard to do good for the people that I
care about. Storytelling has always been
a way for me to escape and experience
things I wouldn't be able to physically.
It gave me an opportunity to kind of get
a taste of things that I knew I would
never be able to do and ways to connect
with the characters and learn and grow
from them. I first started dressing up as
Leia actually when I heard about Carrie
Fisher coming to campus. You know put my hair into buns, found all the white
pieces of clothing I had and threw on my
boots and dressed up as Leia. I always
connected with Leah because I felt like
she's the strongest. Her entire planet
blew up and she just keeps moving
forward. I love Star Wars because it's
just so much fun. It meant more to me
when it became something I used to
connect with other people.
I'm really passionate about working
with disability especially children with
disabilities. I hope to go to law school
after Harvard and work in child welfare
and disability. I struggle a lot but you
know I'm not willing to just like roll
over and die I just have to keep moving
forward and accept where life takes me.